I'm Robert Coons deputy news editor for
physical sciences at science magazine a
process that involves mainly two sets of
people here the new staff of science
magazine and the editors who edit the
scientific papers and then behind us of
course we have all these other resources
we can draw and we have our board of
reviewing editors people who are
scientists we are looking for research
results that either answer some big
question that somebody from people that
are wondering about for a long time or
they seem likely to open the door for a
lot of productive research in the future
or preferably both my favorite
breakthrough was when we did the plain
curry conjecture it was this
mathematical theorem that had been
kicking around for about a century and a
half and people had been working on it
for a long long time lots of false
starts and finally somebody proved it
now this year we started off with so a
really low-tech we have this idea jar
that we put in our kitchen and we
encourage people to leave notes in there
with ideas for the breakthroughs and the
only drawback to this method was that it
didn't work nobody left any notes one
reason was that we got a new high-tech
coffee maker in there and it could take
so much concentration to use that thing
that people just didn't have any left
over to think about breakthrough of the
year ideas our breakthrough of the year
cancer immunotherapy is very different
from all of the breakthroughs that I can
remember we have preliminary results
this year from two different methods
that are very encouraging but they are
so preliminary that we were kind of
afraid of this one
when we were saying giving do we really
dare say this because people will think
we're saying that there's a cure for
cancer and there isn't but we thought
that after talking to oncologists and
other physicians and various kinds of
biomedical researchers they were so
excited about this and they said this is
so promising and it has the potential
the
to save a lot of lives that we decided
that we would just go for it
you